-You can catch our next guest
on the CMT Awards,
airing Monday,
performing his #1 song,
"'Til You Can't"
from "Human: The Double Album."
Here is Cody Johnson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ You can tell your old man ♪
♪ You'll do some largemouth
fishing another time ♪
♪ You just got too much on your
plate to bait and cast a line ♪
♪ You can always put
a rain check in his hand ♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪♪
♪ You can keep putting off
forever ♪
♪ With that girl
whose heart you hold ♪
♪ Swearing that you'll ask some
day further down the road ♪
♪ You can always put a diamond
on her hand ♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪♪
♪ If you got a chance, take it ♪
♪ Take it while you got
a chance ♪
♪ If you got a dream, chase it ♪
♪ 'Cause a dream
won't chase you back ♪
♪ If you're gonna love
somebody ♪
♪ Hold 'em as long and as strong
and as close as you can ♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪ There's a box
of greasy parts ♪
♪ Sitting in the trunk
of that '65 ♪
♪ Still waiting on you
and your granddad ♪
♪ To bring it back to life ♪
♪ You can always get around
to fixing up that Pontiac ♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪♪
♪ If you got a chance, take it ♪
♪ Take it while you got
a chance ♪
♪ If you got a dream, chase it ♪
♪ 'Cause a dream won't chase you
back ♪
♪ If you're gonna love
somebody ♪
♪ Hold 'em as long and as strong
and as close as you can ♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪♪
♪ So take that phone call from
your momma and just talk away ♪
♪ 'Cause you'll never know
how bad you wanna ♪
♪ 'Til you can't someday ♪
♪ Don't wait on tomorrow
'cause tomorrow may not show ♪
♪ Just say your sorries,
your I-love-yous ♪
♪ 'Cause man, you never know ♪
♪ If you got a chance, take it ♪
♪ Take it while you got
a chance ♪
♪ If you got a dream, chase it ♪
♪ 'Cause a dream won't chase
you back ♪
♪ If you're gonna love
somebody ♪
♪ Hold 'em as long and as strong
and as close as you can ♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪ Yeah, if you got a chance ♪
♪ Take it ♪
♪ Take it while
you got a chance ♪
♪ If you got a dream, chase it ♪
♪ 'Cause a dream won't chase you
back ♪
♪ If you're gonna love
somebody ♪
♪ Hold 'em as long and as strong
and as close as you can ♪
♪ Until you can't ♪
♪♪
♪ 'Til you can't ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Take it ♪
♪♪